[Music]
if you're like most fans of the kissing
booth you've probably wondered where
you've seen Joey King before the answers
may surprise you stick around until the
end to find out why her sweet voice
might be so familiar don't forget to
give this video a thumbs up if you love
the kissing booth but before we start
make sure you check out our friends over
at the trendy if you want to stay
up-to-date with your favorite musicians
now let's check out more facts about
Joey King if you're anything like us you
couldn't wait to sit down and watch the
Netflix summer hit the kissing booth the
film took the streaming site by storm
and has proven to be one of their most
popular original titles fans everywhere
swooned over Joey's endearing
performance as Elle Evans you may have
recognized her right away or racked your
brain trying to place her if you feel
like you've seen Joey before you have
let's take a look at the many roles you
may recognize her from like many actors
in Hollywood Joey began acting when she
was a child
fans got their very first glimpse of her
work on an episode of The Suite Life of
Zack and Cody
she appeared on the Disney Channel hit
when she was just seven years old the
show was nominated for an Emmy no less
than three times fans everywhere
followed the adventures of the Tipton
twins Zack and Cody who lived in a hotel
in one episode Zack volunteers himself
and his brother to help out in the
hotel's daycare center when emergencies
call together tendons away the twins are
left alone with the younger kids they
quickly realized they're in over their
heads one of the kids in their care is
Emily played by Joey she does a stellar
job portraying the bratty bully she
really puts the Tipton boys in their
places in one scene she even tells Zack
she hates him
give me one from shoving crayons down a
babysitter's shirt to vandalizing the
hotel Emily gets up to a lot of
shenanigans after her comedic debut Joey
decided to show the world her range in
stark contrast to her first role her
next appearance would be far more
serious playing the title role in the
short film grace Joey delivers a star
performance the story begins with Ray a
woman deeply troubled and depressed Ray
has contemplated ending her own life and
saw no hope she takes a trip to the
ocean to drown herself in the sea then
she meets five-year-old grace grace
appears to ray in her darkest hour with
a little pink suitcase she says she
needs help making it to a meeting with
her boyfriend the adorable grace breaks
through Ray's darkness ray slowly learns
to embrace life again and is saved by
grace the actor played another role
named grace years later this role was
far more whimsical and light-hearted in
the film wish I was here Joey plays the
role of grace bloom blooms father Aidan
is a struggling actor in LA his wife
works a dull day job to support him and
their two kids the family is also
supported by their grandfather who
stipulates that the kids must attend an
Orthodox Jewish school after becoming
ill Grace's grandfather decides to
invest all of his remaining money into
his stem-cell treatment of course this
means that the Blum children can no
longer attend to their school Aidan
decides to home-school his children as
his children learn about life
so does Aidan this role continues to
showcase her professional range in the
classic dr. Seuss tell horton hears a
who
an elephant horton discovers a whole
community on a tiny flower through
meeting the hoos horton learns a lot
about respects and the value of life
joey provides the voice for Katy Katy a
tiny fuzzy yellow creature is a friend
of horton the character deliver some
hysterical lines during a scene in which
Hortons friends pretend that they have
discovered their own tiny worlds Katy
describes hers to a delighted horton in
my world everyone is a pony and they all
eat rainbows and poof butterflies
that's beautiful Katie talked about a
great comedic line that wasn't her only
voice-over role she's taken she also had
a minor role in ice age dawn of the
dinosaurs as a beaver girl Joey has also
played major character roles in animated
films she plays Jessie in both animated
Boxcar Children films the film's bring
the classic book series to life these
beloved books were initially published
in 1924 and followed the adventures of
the Alden children there are 150 titles
in the series the stories follow these
orphaned kids as they build a secret
home together in a boxcar the kids are
resourceful ambitious and hard-working
Jesse is the oldest of the Alden girls
Jesse is the caretaker of her family she
cooks for the other children and does
the housekeeping Jessie's dedication to
her family is a major theme of the
series Joey's voice captures her warmth
and energy her next role would also be
based on a beloved children's book
series the Ramona series of novels
follows the lives of the Quimby family
the characters are warm real and
relatable Ramona Quimby is a character
who has melted hearts since 1955 you
might think a character from the 50s
couldn't be relevant today many of the
books contain everyday struggles that
are timeless
mr. Quimby loses his job for example
that's an issue that has always affected
families a huge part of why the Ramona
novel series continues to do so well is
because they touch on the importance of
family being a part of a family lifts
you up but it isn't easy
little Ramona Quimby uses her
imagination to escape this can often be
frustrating for her family she
particularly irritates her logical older
sister Beezus in this role Joey captured
the Colette si whimsical and often
infuriating Ramona this role was many
people's first introduction to the young
actress she already had an impressive 16
credits to her name before her title
role as the young quindi Joey
established herself as a talented actor
well before the age of 10 she appeared
in roles that were both comedic and
dramatic and nailed both as she got
older she began taking on some more
age-appropriate parts in tween fests
Joey plays the daughter of a clueless
single dad
Todd Todd attempts to throw an epic
festival to impress his internet-famous
daughter his daughter Madison has a
popular video channel with a gross twist
all of her videos are of herself popping
pimples the festival is held in the
middle of the desert and features huge
social media stars
Todd struggles to keep egos from
destroying his dream he's desperate to
look cool in front of his skin grooming
daughter the festival in the film has
been described as burning man meets
VidCon after tween fests Joey moved on
to the superhero genre by appearing on
the show the flash its premiere was the
second most watched on the CW after
airing the show follows the
crime-fighting career of Alan Alan was a
mundane crime scene investigator until
he was struck by lightning after the
lightning strike Alan found he had
superhuman speed Alan uses his newfound
power to fight crime in Central City
Joey plays the role of magenta also
known as Frankie cane magenta also has
superpowers
unlike Alan Frankie didn't get her
powers after a natural events Frankie
was given her powers by dr. alchemy
magenta has the ability to control
magnetism she never wanted to be a
metahuman she tried to lead a mundane
healthy life her role as a villain is a
significant departure from the rest of
the body of her work her range is
breathtaking as we watch her bounce from
voicing small characters to terrorizing
an entire city not many actresses have
played the variety of roles Joey has at
such a young age there is nothing she
can't do Joey shines in comedies family
films dramas and even horror she's
indeed a gifted actor her roles in
horror films are particularly impressive
she has appeared in several horror roles
this far in her career in the terrifying
movie a wish upon a young troubled
Claire played by Joey finds a box with
the dark powers the box is covered in
inscriptions which Claire believes to be
Chinese she's able to translate one of
the inscriptions on the strange
container
it reads seven wishes unaware of the
danger Claire sarcastically wishes for a
classmate to rot the classmate is later
hospitalized with a flesh-eating
bacteria Claire discovers her dog dad in
her attic and realizes the box grants
wishes but at a deadly price her next
horror role tackles Slender Man
chronicles the horrifying story of four
young girls the friends find themselves
sucked into the lore behind Internet
legend Slender Man the story takes a
turn when one of them goes missing it's
up to Joey's character and her friends
to get her back the girls delve into the
online myth and creepypasta surrounding
the mysterious tall creature she
continued her horror roles in the
conjuring the Perron family purchased an
old farmhouse in Rhode Island they are
happy to move into the house unaware of
trouble ahead Joey plays one of the five
Perron daughters shortly after they move
in one of the Perron daughters finds a
boarded-up entrance to a cellar
paranormal occurrences began almost
immediately the family call in the
paranormal investigators
ed and Lorraine Warren after the family
is repeatedly attacked the Warren's
perform an exorcism and liberate the
family from their terror
Joey has provided her voice for several
animated characters as Loretta crews in
Madden 19 longshot homecoming she adds
video games to her body of work as well
she was obviously thrilled to work on
the project an Instagram post revealed
to her fans just how excited she was she
took to Instagram to announce she had
just done a cool thing she said she had
an incredible time and really enjoyed
her first emotion capture work it's
obvious Joey was happy to add another
genre to her resume we can't blame her
for an actor who's appeared in
everything from animated series to
featured films adding a new medium is a
big deal the actor got to show off a
combination of skills in Oz the great
and powerful the film features Joey in
two roles in case
she portrays a young woman in a
wheelchair this role required her to use
her excellent acting skills her second
role China girl she flexes her voiceover
muscles china girl is a living porcelain
doll
the character is theatrical and
emotional adding a third skillset to the
production Joey also had to film in CGI
sets in interviews about her filming
experience
she said the project was something
entirely new for her she said she
enjoyed the unique experience and tried
to make it her own
this production allowed Joey to push
herself as an actress it's not every day
that you appear on camera as a voice
actor and in CGI scenes perhaps Joey's
most emotional project is borealis in
this film she plays a girl named Aurora
Aurora is the visibly impaired daughter
of a man with a gambling addiction her
father finds himself in debt to an
unscrupulous moneylender known as the
rabbi lost and overwhelmed Aurora's dad
takes her on a bonding road trip to see
the Northern Lights before she loses her
sights entirely borealis is an emotional
film about the value of family and the
ability to see what really matters this
role shows the world perhaps the most
serious and mature side of Joey she
isn't running from ghosts or specters
she isn't getting up to hilarious and
over-the-top hijinks she's simply and
profoundly human she bares her soul to
the camera and shares herself with her
audience it's no wonder why fans of the
kissing booth recognized Joey's famous
face she's been in front of the camera
for so long if you couldn't shake the
feeling that you'd seen her before now
you know why it's because she was our
calamitous friends Ramona she's been
sweet innocent terrified and more we've
been watching her blossom for years her
career started while she was still in
elementary school it's almost as if
we've watched her grow up as a person as
well as an actor the prolific actress
has taken quite a number of roles her
career heated up even more after the
kissing booth and isn't showing any
signs of cooling down
Joey's fans will be glad to hear she's
worked on six film projects since the
release of the kissing booth if you
can't get enough of this talented young
lady you won't have to wait long for
your neck
fix with more than 57 credits to her
name she's already had an incredible
career we can't wait to see what the
kissing booth star will work on next we
hope you love this video before you go
don't forget to check out our friends at
the trendy if you love Camila Cabello
ariana grande nicki minaj and other
chart-topping artists you'll absolutely
love their videos they're experts on
pretty much anything music related so
make sure you give them a like see you
later
[Music]